>>Teacher: And our goal next
year is to be the only YES campus
that has ever been
exemplary every single year.
>>All: [cheers]
>>Narrator: You can see it
at an end-of-year assembly
and on the soccer field in the
student-versus-faculty match.
>>All: [cheers]
>>Narrator: The students
of YES Prep North Central
and their teachers actually like
each other, and they like being here.
The positive energy on campus
makes fences and cameras
and security guards unnecessary.
There are few, if any, fights.
This ideal environment for learning
is the product of several programs
and initiatives that
promote the school culture
and support self-discipline.
>>Student: RISE stands for "restoring
individual student excellence."
Being in RISE has made me realize
that you can't always get away
with the little things in life.
>>Narrator: By incurring five marks
in one week for infractions ranging
from chewing gum in
class to dishonesty,
the students in white T-shirts
have been placed on RISE,
a strict disciplinary system
that requires a daily visit
to the principal's office until
their transgressions are balanced
by good behavior.
>>Alexander: Well, I got five marks
and I got it for talking, and,
yeah, so I'm not proud of it.
Literally it sucks, yeah.
It sucks. I'm going to try
harder to get off and be back
with my group right there.
>>Philip: Look at this thing.
Does this show me that you're
trying hard to get off RISE?
>>I just kind of go with
the way I was raised.
My parents showed me a ton of love
but were also extremely direct
and stern when I screwed up, and
that's the way I talk to the students
in checking them in the morning RISE.
>>This is a small example
of what's going to happen
for the rest of your life.
If you make poor decisions,
you're going to miss
out on the great opportunities.
>>I think kind of the approach
with the RISE is, look,
I care about you tremendously.
I really want you to be successful.
I'm not giving up on you,
but you've let me down
and you've let your classmates down.
You've let your teachers down,
but each day is a new day
to hold themselves responsible
for their behaviors and that they,
with their actions, can
get back into the community
and be a part of the family again.
>>You've done a great
job, so keep it up.
Have a good day.
>>Narrator: While they're on
the RISE, students are separated
from their classmates
during lunch and assemblies.
In class they are forbidden to speak
unless it is academically essential.
After logging five days
of positive behavior,
they address their classmates
to explain why they are
worthy of reuniting with them.
>>Student: Dear classmates,
I am writing this letter
to inform you the reason I was
in respect to RISE for so long.
>>Student: How will you prove to us
that you won't get on RISE again?
>>Student: Because whenever a
teacher's talking I will slant
towards here, and whenever
a student tries to talk
to me I will just raise my hand
and tell her I need to move.
>>Teacher: You ready
to change, Tatiana?
Welcome back.
>>Class: [claps]
>>Alexander: RISE is an
important thing here,
because it teaches your students
how to improve from their errors,
and I really believe that.
>>Teacher: All right, highs and lows?
Who wants to start us?
>>Narrator: Students
meet for one period
with their class adviser
several times each week.
It's an opportunity for them
to be heard and supported.
>>Student: Her portfolios, I was glad
that my mom was there, because I felt
like she supported me, and usually
she can't, because she's working
and stuff, so I was really
proud of that, happy.
>>Philip: Every student in the
school has someone that they can kind
of go to, who knows them well, who
maybe knows their ups and downs
and often is not their
same classroom teacher.
>>Student: I think it's
important for us to be heard,
to let people know our feelings,
because if we keep things balled
up it can get worse, and
we don't want each other
to get hurt, because it can escalate.
>>Magda: In advisory it's talking
about how do we communicate
our frustrations, our ideas?
How do we handle tough situations?
It's talking about, what
does it mean to be Hispanic?
What does it mean to be a minority?
>>Now, I want everybody to lock
in their mind one emotional need
that they value, and what
happens when you don't feel
like that emotional need is not
being -- it's not being met?
>>Narrator: History teacher Magda
Derisma did extensive research
and consulted with the school
counselor before settling
on a theme for her advisory.
>>Class: We have your
back and we are listening.
>>Magda: It kind of took me a
while in my head to actually figure
out what the words were actually
going to be, and I said, okay,
I like these set of words.
It's like, "We have your
back and we are listening."
It just shows that we're
supporting you and we are listening
to what you say, so that they
know that empathy is important,
just to sit down and listen to
what somebody else is saying
and how do we support someone else
and actually give them
advice in a concrete way.
>>Student: So, since
this school is supposed
to be a family-oriented school,
so instead of us being separated
into different groups of
friends, we need to mix it up
and have different people
instead of just one little group.
>>Chris: The signage and the
messaging and when you walk
into a classroom, I mean, there's
stuff up all over the walls.
All that's intentional.
When I was a teacher, I
mean, my goal was that even
if the kids aren't paying
attention to me and they're looking
around the room or daydreaming, I
want them learning something, right?
There really has to be kind of
a marketing campaign every day
around why are you here,
what this is going to lead to
and why college is really important.
So, part of it is just making sure
that kids are getting
the right messages,
because when they're not
here, they're bombarded
with a whole other set of them,
whether it's on TV
or from their peers.
And so, if we're not aware
of that and trying to fight
that with positive messaging
here, we're fooling ourselves.
>>Craig: One thing our school is
really big on is something called the
"Thinks and Acts," and they were
created by a group of students,
who said, "We want to leave YES
with something to remember us by,"
and basically they say, "This is
how YES students should think.
This is how a YES student should
act," not just in school but outside
of school, too, and so we
really challenge our students.
We say, "Hey, are you
living the Thinks and Acts?
Are you living the blue-orange?"
>>Chris: I feel like one of my jobs
and the jobs of the leaderships
across this organization is to make
sure that we're living those signs,
that we're living those values
and that we are walking,
breathing examples of the kind
of people we want our kids to be.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.